mais d'abord je voudrais avoir une
pensée pour la famille colonnes qui est
une famille avec qui nous avons plus de
40 ans de lutte pour le peuple corse et
qui aujourd'hui se trouve face à une
tragédie ne se résignent annoncé comme
jeudi au début cette colère cette colère
d'un état qui qui n'entendent pas la
voie des corses qui n'entendent pas le
la voie de la démocratie cela fait
maintenant des années que nous demandons
le rapprochement des prisonniers
politiques en corse pour la raison
suivante on le sait ils sont en danger
dans les prisons est toujours un état
sourd à nos demandes et de résultat
aujourd'hui catastrophique
catastrophique et dramatique
l'état a failli des responsables de la
prison ont failli ils le reconnaissent
je crois que
on peut parler aujourd'hui d'une
vengeance d'état pont pourra le dire
comme ça va jaser ça parce que je veux
dire c'est quelque chose qui était
annoncé quelque chose qui avaient été
eux qui avait été dit il ya plusieurs
reprises nous avons
vu le garde des sceaux nous avons un
manifester nous avons clamer haut et
fort le rapprochement des prisonniers
politiques
à chaque fois il y a eu une réponse de
non recevoir
cela a trop duré et le risque étant
imminent le drame est arrivé un beau jeu
sur eric dupond-moretti dont vous parlez
est silencieux et
qu'il prenne la parole quelque chose
je crois que monsieur dupont moretti est
tenue la discrétion du fait qu'il était
de l'avocat divan colonnes mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui
il ne peut plus ne peut plus se cacher
derrière un mutisme derrière une affaire
qu'il a connu je crois qu'il est temps
que que le garde des sceaux prenne la
parole son agression l'agression divan
colonnes et sa mort du coup est ce que
pour vous ça peut relancer les violences
et nous nous sommes face à une famille
avec une très grande dignité qui lors
des manifestations toujours appelé au
calme face une famille qui a souffert
encore aujourd'hui suite à son décès
elle demande à que sa mémoire soit
respectée a que le calme soit présent en
corse voilà je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est l'appât j'appelle bien sûr au
calme et c'est la parole du bon sens
c'est aussi à quoi aspirent les corses
il faut arrêter d'être humilié il faut
arrêter d'être méprisés par cet état
[Musique]